With Captain America: Civil War about to kick
off Phase 3 of Marvel’s Cinematic Universe,
many fans have been revisiting the films that
have led up to this epic battle of the titans.
Disney and Marvel studio head Kevin Feige
have done an excellent job overall, but you
don’t build a billion dollar franchise without
making a few mistakes along the way.
Here are the 10 Biggest Movie Mistakes The
MCU Has Made So Far
Ant-Man vs Falcon
Marvel takes every opportunity to remind us
that all of these films take place in the
same Universe, even if that means unnecessary
cameos.
Ant-Man had potential to be the only true
standalone film in MCU’s Phase 2, but just
in case people weren’t sure what universe
they were in, they squeezed in an awkward
confrontation between Ant Man and secondary
Avenger Falcon.
The whole scene reeks of studio notes and
reshoots.
At Marvel the studio always trumps the director,
which has cost them the talents of Edgar Wright,
and who knows who else.
2.
Ed Norton as Hulk
The Incredible Hulk is probably the most disconnected
of all the films in the MCU, and a big part
of that is because of its lead.
Edward Norton is the only Avenger who needed
to be recast after a standalone film, although
replacing him had very little to do with his
performance.
Like his character in Birdman, Norton can
be as intense offscreen as he is onscreen
and had very specific ideas about the Hulk
that didn’t always line up with Marvel’s.
He refused to do publicity for the film, and
wasn’t the team player the studio needed
for their Avengers initiative.
3.
Black Widow
As much as we love Black Widow and Scarlett
Johansson’s portrayal of her, the movies
seem to have a difficult time knowing what
to do with her.
Black Widow is primarily a utility player
used to fill in plot holes and tick boxes.
Her relationship with the other Avengers seems
to depend on whose movie she’s in.
Always the bridesmaid, never a bride, we all
know Black Widow could hold her own in a standalone
movie if they just gave her a chance.
4.
No stakes
With so many mini franchises feeding into
this mega franchise, it’s become like a
towering Jenga game that Marvel is afraid
will topple if they remove one block.
We’re a dozen films in and even though the
fate of many has been at stake every time,
they’ve still only killed off minor characters
like Agent Coulson and Quicksilver, only one
of whom stayed dead.
They wouldn’t even follow through on deaths
like Nick Fury in Winter Soldier or Pepper
Potts in Iron Man 3, even though these wouldn’t
have had a very large ripple effect.
While Marvel doesn’t need to be as dark
or serious as DC, we still need to feel these
characters are at risk if we’re expected
to remain invested.
5.
Steve Rogers' CGI Body
To show Steve Roger’s pre-serum body in
Captain America: The First Avenger the filmmakers
used CGI to put Chris Evans’ face onto another
actor’s body.
It’s an advanced technique that sometimes
comes off as crude and unfinished.
In some scenes you can barely notice it, but
there are times when it becomes strange, distracting,
and almost humorous.
Even if you’re not supposed to take Rogers
seriously for the first third of the movie,
The First Avenger would have benefitted from
a little more time in the post production
lab.
6.
Terrence Howard
It’s still a little unclear what happened
with Terrence Howard that caused him to be
replaced by Don Cheadle as Colonel Rhodes
for the second Iron Man and subsequent Avenger
films, but there’s clearly some bad blood
there.
Howard is known for being a little eccentric
so many of suspected his on set behaviour
could have had something to do with it.
On several occasions Howard has blamed Robert
Downey Jr. and his big pay raise between films
for muscling him out.
Regardless of the reason, the superb Cheadle
is almost five films into his Marvel run and
nobody seems to miss Howard.
7.
“I’m always Angry”
Avengers was the first film that really made
the Hulk work.
Like Ruffalo’s Banner, director Joss Whedon
learned how to control the Hulk and use him
for good as opposed to just having an out
of control rage monster.
When Banner shows up for the final battle,
he reveals his secret to taming the Hulk:
He’s always angry.
It sounds cool and has become a highly quotable
line, but it actually poses more questions
than it answers.
How did he turn the one thing that triggers
the Hulk into something that subdues him?
Why is he so mad all the time?
Fortunately he punches out a giant space whale
before we can think too much about it.
8.
Whiplash
It’s been said a superhero movie is only
as good as its villain, perhaps this is why
Iron Man 2 catches so much flack.
Ivan Vanko aka Whiplash was a strange choice
for Iron Man’s second outing.
Vanko is supposed to be as brilliant as Stark,
so it seems odd that after figuring out the
tech that powers the Iron Man suit that he
would apply it to something as basic as whips.
Everything about the character, from his his
motivation, to his look, to Mickey Rourke’s
weird Russian accent just didn’t mesh for
audiences.
In the end it was Sam Rockwell’s more comedic
villain Justin Hammer who was the more amusing
foil.
9.
Tacked on Love Stories
It seems like to matter how many worlds are
colliding, origin stories being told, or crossovers
being justified, there’s always time for
a little love.
These subplots usually feel unnecessary and
shoehorned in.
The most blatant example of this would probably
be the relationship between Thor and Jane
Foster, which isn’t developed at all but
we’re just supposed to accept.
Marvel has no shortage of strong female characters,
they just came seem to find strong stories
for them.
10.
Spoiling Spidey in Civil War Trailer
As exciting as the trailers for Captain American:
Civil War make it look, there’s an overshadowing
sense that we’ve seen it all already.
The main event is the Avengers fighting one
another, but even that we’ve seen.
Perhaps this is why they felt the need to
show the addition of fan favourite Spider-Man
in the second trailer.
This is the kind of reveal that should be
saved for the first time you see the film.
It would be a moment that would make audiences
cheer in the theatre, but now it’s just
something they’ll wait for.
It’s hard to imagine Civil War containing
any surprises that would be as big or fun
as that one.
I guess the execs got a little too excited
about finally coming to an agreement with
Sony to use the wall crawler and slung their
web too soon.
While we love what Marvel has done with their
cinematic universe, nobody is perfect, but
at least they seem to be learning from their
mistakes as they perfect the formula they
helped invent.
What MCU missteps bothered you?
Let us know in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe for more videos like this one.